are you ready to see the Taylor Swift
eras tour in your hometown without
snagging hard to get concert tickets who
are we getting of course you are welcome
to the eras tour we're all ready to
check out the era's tour movie when it
hits theaters and we need all the Deeds
here's everything we know about this
history making movie theater moment
Taylor Swift's era's tour has broken
some serious records already it's
predicted that this will be the highest
grossing tour in history and it's even
believed that the tour has boosted the
US economy it's no surprise then that
Taylor is committed to making this tour
even bigger than it already is and we're
lucky enough to be reaping the benefits
folks anticipate the eras tour movie
being so big that other movies have
moved their own release dates to avoid
conflicting with the tour movie opening
as soon as she announced that she was
coming out with this film anybody who
had a movie coming out that day pulled
out the movie is expected to earn more
than 90 6 million in its opening weekend
alone it's also predicted to become the
most successful filmed concert ever
surpassing Justin Bieber Never Say Never
the movie will open on October 13th and
while it certainly won't be exactly the
same as seeing the arrows Tour live
there's reason to believe that seeing
the era's tour movie will feel a lot
like the real thing in her post
announcing the arrows tour movie Taylor
said the era's tour has been the most
meaningful electric experience of my
life so far and I'm Overjoyed to tell
you that it'll be coming to the big
screen soon not only did Taylor let us
know just how excited she is for this
new iteration of her tour she also set
the tone for what exactly the experience
will be when watching the tour in
theaters she added era's attire
friendship bracelets singing and dancing
encouraged discussion of era's tour
attire has been all the rage since the
tour first kicked off folks go all out
dressing like their favorite Taylor era
or references to one of her songs after
the Barbie movie hit theaters we've all
seen just how willing people are to
dress to the nines from movies these
days so it's safe to say that the eras
tour in movie theaters will be no
exception attending it is about more
than just watching a performance and
hearing live music the tour created a
sense of community and the concerts were
major events Taylor Swift clearly wants
to bring this feeling to everyone so
making and handing out friendship
bracelets singing and dancing around the
movie theater and dressing up is just as
important as getting your movie ticket
and your popcorn if you're a fan of
Taylor Swift then you know how much the
star loves leaving Easter eggs for all
her eagle-eyed fans these have been all
over her tour and we're certain to see
them when the movie hits theaters from
her gold dress and silver guitar from
her fearless era to her not a lot going
on at the moment t-shirt being swapped
out for a a lot going on at the moment
true fans had plenty to pick up at the
eras tour even the price of her movie
ticket is an Easter egg ticket price is
going to be 19.89 I heard and yes even
that magical release date of October
13th is an Easter egg my first song that
ever went number one it had a 13 second
intro I'm even doing that on purpose
Taylor was far from the only star
featured in her tour so it's safe to say
that she won't be the only star featured
in the movie either the era's tour has
had special guests and openers including
Paramore Biba doobie Phoebe Bridges Owen
Gracie Abrams girl in red and Gail and
we're sure to see these and maybe even
more in the movie besides getting a
chance to see the other stars who've
accompanied Taylor on her tour there
have been other moments that plenty of
fans were sad to miss speak now was
released from its box hinting at the
fact that it would be the next
re-recorded album to be released there
was a standing ovation in one of her La
shows that lasted eight minutes after
Taylor performed champagne problems she
replaced songs concert goers expected to
hear with ones they didn't and was
joined on stage by stars like Adam
desner and Marcus Mumford these special
moments are some of the things that make
the eras tour so unique and it's what
makes every night different of course
many of these iconic moments from the
tour can't be repeated so they won't be
shown in the movie but it's safe to say
that it will have its fair share of new
once in a lifetime moments the era's
tour hasn't just attracted record
numbers of fans and surprise special
guests on stage it's also attracted
plenty of VIPs to the audience from Emma
Stone to Sydney Sweeney Taylor Lautner
and Selena Gomez no one has famous
friends and fans quite like Taylor Swift
who will we be able to spot on the big
screen at the era's tour movie only time
will tell but we have a feeling it will
be star-studded the eras tour movie
promises to be a lot like the live shows
plus it's going to be an event all on
its own you're gonna have like the merch
the popcorn merch everything's going to
be all themed for the movie Yes it seems
that movie theaters are simply another
stop on the eras tour so get your outfit
together make your friendship bracelets
and get ready to sing your heart out in
the movie theater closest to you have
you gotten your tickets to see the
arrows tour movie yet what are you most
looking forward to seeing on the big
screen let's talk about it in the
comments and for more videos like this
one like And subscribe to the things